on TV on Radio and on your smartphone
this is talk TV
[Music]
tonight on Facebook and uncensored fears
for the queen as she postpones another
formal engagement doctors have now
ordered the 96 year old Monarch to rest
use crime rising and fears of a gang
violence could teach us smacking kids
again be the answer a store in America
brings back corporal punishment
and militant vegans on the warpath
vandalizing Big Ben and gluing
themselves to the road demanding we all
go meat free
we are here outside the house of
parliament with confirmed members of
animal Rebellion asking the government
to transition to
up the system
I'll be going to Toe with one of those
protesters right here live
live from London this is Piers Morgan
uncensored well good evening welcome to
Piers Morgan on Center prime minister
Liz truss met with her cabinet for the
first time today and these were the
proud smiling faces of the people she's
charged were sifting through the rubble
of a broken Nation they all look quite
cheerful don't they like they don't know
what's going to happen to them or us but
these are the people we have to trust
now to rebuild a country where families
can pay their bills where businesses can
hope to survive the next six months well
the lights actually stay on this winter
A lot's been said and written about this
top team already apparently this trust
is now the sole survivor of the David
Cameron Administration
we're told it's the most diverse cabinet
ever not a single one of the four Great
offices of state is now held by a white
man perished the thought but there are
moana's too of course they've grown that
some things never changed because
two-thirds of them are privately
educated others fear she's repeating
Boris Johnson's Mistakes by packing her
Squad with allies and benching the
experienced players some critics have
even rather impedently wondered why
cigar chomping plus size karaoke van is
our new health secretary
but here's the point
I don't care
I don't care where they went to school I
don't care if I get to go on a plane I
like a cigar and a pint I don't care if
they voted leave or remain I don't care
if they'd back Boris or supported
Richard suneck I don't care if they're
black white or Screaming Violet this is
a wartime cabinet quite literally given
what's going on in Ukraine all the
British people care about us whether
they can fix this Unholy mess list prom
list trust keeps promising us she can
the word she keeps using is I will
deliver deliver deliver
in her campaign to be leader and our
prime minister she made a staggering 149
policy pledges
149 this new cabinet has a lot to live
up to if they can step up and deliver as
she says they can the country will not
only back them every step of the way
we'll cheer them when they do it but if
they break those promises
if they don't deliver
if the country gets worse not better
we'll be watching and we will hold them
to brutal account well joining me now
are my peers back talkatively
contributor Esther cracker broadcaster
and journalist Jenny cleeman and this is
very exciting the BBC's International
editor and author Jeremy Bowen welcome
thanks for inviting me please
it adds A Touch of Class not the you
leave
but A Touch of Class
um
what a star uh well first of all welcome
to all three of you obviously I want to
start first of all with the queen
because we've just seen her in this
unprecedented uh situation where Boris
Johnson and Liz trust got up to Balmoral
for the first time uh to do the official
process of the Handover to be prime
minister and she did look okay but she
looked for it I mean the pictures she
just looked fresh she's 96 years old
yeah exactly yeah uh now we hear that
she took a term for the worse she's got
to spend some time now resting she
couldn't attend a privy council meeting
after doctors intervened ongoing health
issues obviously I guess Jeremy for me
as you're the nearest to her age
obviously
[Laughter]
um what do you think about all this
because it seems we've only known one
Monarch in our lifetimes yeah yeah I
just feel like it's going to be such a
seismic moment when she's not here
anymore I think that the national
outpouring world might even dwarf what
happened when Diana was killed I think
it's going to be absolutely huge and a
national trauma of the greatest extent
yeah you're quite right I was born in
1960 she's already been on the throne
for eight years yeah at that point it's
amazing isn't it yeah it's absolutely
amazing and you've traveled the world
where they don't have monarchies
what do you think of the institution of
the monarchy in the modern times well I
think it's work for Britain uh I think
the queen herself is a national figure
like no other you're in a university
respected uh even by people who say they
don't agree with the monarchy the
[Music]
what will happen after that I think
people might ask more questions because
of course there's you know there is
there are people who say that maybe
we've had enough of the royal family but
I think that while the Queen's there uh
of course those questions are very much
on hold one of the problems Esther is we
have the Duke and Duchess of Sussex and
all that drama going on a report tonight
from Omid scoby this in my opinion
revolting little specimen it keeps
popping up as the sussex's licks metal
mouthpiece and keeps trashing the Royals
on their behalf tonight trashing Prince
William saying that he believes until
William admits his accountability for
all the Terrible Things he's done to
Megan and Harry they can't be reconciled
they're literally in Windsor Park
tonight yes half a mile from each other
these two boys
and they haven't even said hello to each
other this is damaging it's not just
damaging to them and their relationship
it's damaging to Charles who also hasn't
seen Harry and apparently I was told on
good authority this week he feels
incredibly hurt by what's going on he's
going to be king sooner rather than
later probably but this is also damaging
to the foundation of the monarchy I
think this is now the best time for the
the monarchy to transition and I think I
know no one has made this point but I do
think the queen should abdicate because
I do think the country you won't do that
she won't because of her sense of Duty
but I know it's actually because they
believe in the natural law of succession
they believe that it once you interfere
with that I was told this by somebody
senior in the royal family that if you
start interfering with the natural
process you then let other things come
into play for example if the queen was
to abdicate and Prince Charles gets
killed in the car crash the next day God
forbid you have a constitutional crisis
which is why they don't abdicate I mean
we've had one in the last you know a few
hundred years but I think that the the
issue the royal family has is how do you
Rebrand how do you become more tolerable
because obviously we're seeing this Feud
with Harry and and William and I think
it's very unpalative and I think it's
actually a disgrace to the Queen's
Legacy and what she's built worked so
hard to build and you have these two
freeloaders
um on the other side of the world just
basically making money off her Legacy
and of her years of hard work I do think
that maybe it's time okay she won't
abdicate maybe Prince Charles should
step up and take sort of more yeah I
think the monarchy was devised at a time
when you could never imagine someone
living 96 years and the thing about the
queen is she is all about dignity that's
why she doesn't want to be seen uh you
know in a wheelchair or with Mobility
AIDS she's a very dignified person and I
think her having to continue until the
very end kind of goes counter to that
and and again with the the Harry and
Megan big business you do have to think
about the question of dignity and I
don't think there is there is anybody
Republican or otherwise who would who
would say that the queen is not if you
cannot have a renegade Royal fan family
running around whoring those titles to
the highest bidders you can it's
incredibly damaging that's why I've been
on about this for quite a while because
I could see the danger to the actual
future of the monarchy if it looks like
the Royals basically don't do any public
service or Duty they fly around in
private jets preaching about the
environment and then they cash in their
titles to Netflix and Spotify for
hundreds of millions of dollars Harry
and Megan getting more and more
unpopularly so I agree more so in
America they are they are but I think
the damage the drip drip drip damage to
the Integrity of the monarchy it should
not be underestimated to be a
distinction between monarchy and
celebrity they're two separate things
and there isn't which the Queen's always
understood yes which the queen is
understood and I think maybe Megan
didn't understand that when she married
into the royal family oh I think she
understood completely what she wanted
I'm very cynical about it because I
think she's this is all an actress at
the top of her game getting what she
wants out of this using our royal family
to make yourself very rich and famous I
think that will only work as long as
people want to hear her and I think I'm
getting this thing I think the thing is
we we'd find her less distasteful if she
did it for free you know she talks about
all the things that she wants to do
um
actually give up the titles just be
Meghan Markle and Harry right and go and
do your thing I'm fine see how you get
on yeah what I have a problem is is they
come back here to booster their Royal
status to remind people that they are
Royals because that's where the money is
and then they trash the monarchy and the
institution and they trash the other
oils I mean you just can't have it
always anyway uh enough of them um play
a little clip this is Nick curios you're
a tennis fan a little bit Yeah so Nick
curios who's this obviously super brat
good player but a super brat
um did very well at Wimbledon I came up
a little bit short was doing well in the
US Open loses and then he does this
it's coming I'm told we're on baited
breath here
well we don't have it but it's worth
waiting for because Nick kyrgios has
been trying to convince us that he's a
better man yes he says he's overall he's
over all that he's come through it and
he can he can take him he can take
defeat that's no problem it's all okay
and then he threw one of the most
Almighty Tantrums ever say look at this
[Applause]
it's the second one that is so
pathetically childish like Get over some
of your big babies he's just trying to
show that he cares
branding He's the bad boy we're talking
about it it's really not okay it's not
okay like this and it's Serena Williams
had had been violent like that there
would be something well actually Serena
Williams has done stuff like that and
she has been roundly casting to get
something rude to a line judge yes it is
you know that's really really aggressive
it's really nice Jeremy have you ever
smashed things in your job I've still
had a tennis racket I bought about 20
years ago I would never smash it they
cost a bomb because he was striking I've
known you a lifetime you've always
struck me as extraordinarily calm person
when all around is exploding I don't
smash things I mean I'm often surrounded
by people who are smashed yes often with
guns and quite big ones but no I uh I
don't see I mean I guess maybe that's
his way of dealing with his rage and
disappointment I mean she said that but
to be honest I think that if you explode
like that it shows you failed it does
but it also shows this extraordinarily
burning bash that he has inside him like
I don't think Mcenroe could help himself
this
it's terrible it's like it's like people
who beat their spouses you know it's
because just all this passion that I had
for you no get a grip
he's only beating a tennis racket he's
not beating a human I know but you know
you shouldn't display your anger by by
being doing violent acts we've evolved
past this I think but it's entertaining
and they're talking about it
well I think it's Brian don't dignified
I think he's doing it I think he does it
deliberately yeah yeah I think it's
branding I think should we smash up this
table for breakfast well I don't want
that to be my brand the bad girl
the smashes that one I mean that is it's
pathetic if you're watching Mr curious I
think you do watch the show just grow up
you big baby
um Jeremy I want to talk to you quickly
yeah I'm gonna labor this but BBC
impartiality BBC yes on your program yes
I do actually because I'm very curious
where's the line for you with partiality
Emily matless has raised a lot of
questions about it Gary Danica that is
in the news again this week what do you
think there's a long time BBC timer
Gary's in a slightly different
categories he doesn't work for news
that's the argument that he's able to
have a bit more freedom to make these
quite opinionated do you accept that or
does it make life except because it's
the rules I follow the rules mate I mean
I do and uh the uh the director General
my boss said uh in uh the at that
committee the other day at Parliament
that I think it was a work in progress I
don't really means by that maybe he's
going to have a chat with him but I mean
clearly it's controversial for some
people
um on the the whole business of
impartiality journalism is about truth
it's about getting to the truth and it's
about how you get to it now on a this is
a very opinionated program you see it's
in it's written you know it's it's a
wrong sales title yes you get what you
can see on the tin yeah you get what you
can say on the Tim with the BBC as well
which is not my opinions it's not about
me it's not about it's yes it's my
analysis and my observation and I use my
own eyes and my ears and I might even in
the right context talk about something
that happened to me if it's if it
illuminates The Wider issue and in the
course of that what impartiality means
in my head and I think in the bbcs as
well is that we've all got views I mean
my God as I get older My Views get
stronger I've had lunch with you you
made me look like a shrinking violet but
you don't do it on camera well no
um not hot maybe if they paid me
yes I don't know but the thing is is
that
um I I think that the BBC it's quite
clear whatever your views are you stick
them in a box on the door you pick them
up on the way out when when you saw
Emily make this thing on news night
which causes the problem about Dominic
Cummings did you feel did you feel it it
crossed a line yeah I did actually
um I think that it wouldn't have taken a
great deal for to be stay on the right
side of the line
because you know if you you cannot say
this will think that effectively is what
she was saying because actually probably
some people didn't think that I think if
she'd written it a little bit more
cleverly if she'd said
everybody's talking about this this is
what people are saying I mean some of
you out there may disagree but you know
the out the country's up in arms about
Dominic comic I think a lot of people
were but it was the way she said it and
in the context that she said it and in
the you know the the top of uh doing a
kind of soliloquy at the top of a big
time BBC news program was not considered
appropriate and I think it was
appropriate for the bosses to have a
word with her after that interesting she
didn't like it clearly I know she's got
another job it wasn't asking me there's
been a lot of people leaving the BBC you
know from Emily to Andrew Neil to Andrew
Marr all with people lots of people you
haven't heard of who have um taken
redundancy in various things is there
any check that could tempts you to
unleash yourself as an opinionated
monster I'm a BBC man through and
through you know that I think you are
yeah I think you are yeah I am and uh
you know if someone came in and made me
a life-changing offer who knows I
consider it but actually at the moment
it's been nearly 40 years so you know I
only know one way to work and you know
the most disgraceful thing I discovered
today about you you don't have any honor
I think
I'll even be
I don't know one of the greatest
correspondence in BBC history not even
an mbmd is pretty good but you walk
around your Newsroom and you see all
these people with honors they don't wear
them at the office or anything but I
mean that would I went to a state dinner
once and I saw some dip it for uh it was
for the King of Jordan at the Guild Hall
no you'd never do and suddenly all of
these people who had known diplomats the
foreign office were just ripping with
medals and things on sashes around their
necks would you like something the
recognition of your work I'm not quite
happy as I am if I launch a campaign on
social media go ahead you never see what
happens
you can take a short break come back
with more from our pack uh we're talking
about medicine organism because you
don't like milk I just discovered which
is a bizarre Revelation there's any
scoffing cheese like it's gone out of
passion so uh we'll discuss they also
talk about Donald Trump and democracy
because I think those are big issues and
Jeremy's great book The Modern Middle
East of Personality no one knows more
about it than he does talking about that
off the back
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to Piers organizers still
with me at talk TV contributor Esther
Krakow broadcaster and journalist Jenny
Cleveland I'm BBC veteran veteran BBC
veteran do you mind me called a veterans
it's been nearly 40 years you're a
veteran BBC veteran Jeremy Bowen um
let's talk politics for a moment Esther
the cabinet I've got to say it's been a
lot of speculation about you know what
color they all are where they were
educated you know blah blah blah I don't
care yeah all I care is are they any
good can they do their job because I
don't think the public are looking at
them going oh look there's only there's
no white people in the main who cares
what makes the difference and I think at
this time when people are really kind of
in the thick of it and really facing
hard choices we don't actually we
shouldn't care what they look like I
think it's nice you know the device you
know but I think it's more about looking
at their competence as opposed to the
color of their skin someone like crazy
has a fantastic CV I've told people you
know he you couldn't actually find a
more qualified man to be Chancellor but
everyone's saying oh but he's not he's
not real diversity because he may be
black but he doesn't think the right
thing right we are facing a custom
living Christ I'll judge him on what
they do it's judging what they do Jenny
I mean the big issue is energy we're
gonna hear tomorrow we think from Liz
truss about what this big 100 billion
pound plan is we think it's going to be
a cap of two and a half thousand a
person
um the problem is she's also pledged to
cut taxes and I'll be talking about this
all week nobody I've read who I think is
smart in the world of Economics thinks
you can possibly in the current
situation cut taxation when you're
beginning we're going to be borrowing so
much and not have inflation roaring even
higher well she's got this kind of Boris
boosterish it'll all be fine about her
she is the the error we've now learned
from three years of Boris she thinks
that you can do it uh through borrowing
she's found one or two economists who
who back her up she surrounded herself
with people who are loyal and uh she you
know she does not picking people
necessarily I would say on the on their
talent she is picking people according
to how biddable they are and how loyal
they are to her and how willing they are
to sing from the the same him she and
you know we'll we'll see how that gets
on it's quite funny Jacob Reese mogg uh
who is the new uh business business
secretary said in January that he
believed that any new leader should uh
should uh go call a general election in
order to suicidal now he's now not
saying that now they're a business
secretary um you know these people they
don't really have principles very much
they're just people who are who are
going to have uh Liz's back well Jeremy
I mean look I'm principal politicians
are nothing new I think what's new
though in the modern era certainly the
last few years Boris Johnson Donald
Trump you look around other countries
around the world the sort of Rise of
these sort of celebrity leaders
what's your your take on that well I
intellectual terms it's magnetic for a
lot of people they've had a lot of
success it's partly I think a function
of the way that the world is now uh the
way that the the celebrity culture has
morphed into Politics as well and it it
feeds off people's big images I think
politicians there were always big
figures in politics so people still talk
about but but if you bolt on all the
other stuff that comes with being famous
these days then they become much much
larger in America Trump obviously
planning a comeback will probably run
again a poll came out Quinnipiac poll
this week two-thirds of Americans
believe democracy is dying I found that
a terrifying statistic well I think it's
you know it's a great democracy of the
world and uh no it is what's happening
in America in terms of social division
the cultural Wars the way that there are
while they may whoever's in the White
House might try and get one message out
from the federal government there are
lots and lots of different messages come
out from different states vastly
different regulations that they're
bringing in you know in in some states
uh taking action against companies for
being too Green in California saying
that after 2035 you can't sell petrol
Brands yeah you know so it's a very dis
United States of America and the thing
about America was that they managed to
meld together all these forces it was
the great Melting Pot President Biden a
few days ago said this
not every public and not even the
majority Republicans are Maggie
Republicans
not every Republican Embraces their
extreme ideology
but there's no question
that the Republican party today is
dominated driven and intimidated
by Donald Trump and the Maggie
Republicans
and that is a threat to this country now
as to my problem with that is that when
he says Mega Republicans 70 million
people voted for Donald Trump second
time around 10 million more than voted
for him first time right or maybe more
actually
um this is a bit like Hillary Clinton
call them a basket of deplorables is at
the moment you start labeling everyone
who voted for Donald Trump a lunatic or
a Madman whatever you know Biden wants
to call them you alienate half the
country but that's that's the problem
and I think to say that my Republicans
don't make up that much of the
Republican party that's a complete lie
you know Trump's endorsement uh hit rate
is like 90 now if he endorses you
there's a 90 chance you're going to get
elected he's an incredibly powerful
figure in the party because there are
loads of people that are still flocking
to him and this is just deepening the
divisions in in the party and won the
country as a whole I mean Jenny should
he even be allowed to run we've now
discovered that in this FBI raid some of
these highly sensitive top secret
documents included apparently details of
foreign powers nuclear capability and it
was just sitting there at maralongo it
is terrifying and this is not just an
issue for America's national security
it's potentially an issue for ours
because we don't know which countries uh
nuclear codes or nuclear plants uh were
in there so it's it's really serious in
terms of whether or not he should be
allowed to run I mean I don't know what
the rules are of what makes you
ineligible I think people should not
vote for him because as much as you know
you say calling mag or American Maga
Republicans uh you know labeling them in
the same way as Baskets at the basket of
deplorable levels these are I think
Donald Trump ever since he lost to the
election has become far more extreme and
and his whole uh what is this I know
Trump very well he's a sore loser the
problem is when you're a sore loser when
you've lost an election what you're
basically saying is I refuse to accept
democracy yeah and that's why you see
this poll of Americans saying we think
democracy is dying because they see the
guy there's lots of residency still
saying I didn't lose it and you and they
see the raid on Mar-A-Lago as fitting
perfectly into this narrative Trump just
has to say the whole things have fit up
inside Jeremy your book The Modern
Middle East fascinating book I mean
everyone who wants to know about Middle
East you go and read this you've been
pretty much everywhere in the Middle
East you've been shot at stabbed chased
hurried everything
um you know you've been at the sharp end
of it I want to start with Ukraine
because Ukraine is an appalling war on
the face of it it's a ruthless dictator
invading a sovereign Democratic country
when I was in Ukraine and I'm not trying
to come pair of all corresponding
credentials given I spent three days as
one
um but it was fascinating to me that
there were some ukrainians who said that
they felt that russian-speaking parts of
Ukraine like the Crimea perhaps even the
donbass actually a lot of people there
wanted to go back to being part of
Russia does that make it more
complicated or not it is complicated and
it's not a simple story and zelenski
himself was not that popular before The
Invasion he had 30 approval ratings back
in December and then he brought the
country together with uh you know those
extraordinary broadcasts that he was
doing on a nightly basis walking around
Kiev with his bodyguards and recording
things and putting them online no I've
I've spent quite a bit of time in the in
the east in donbass this region uh where
there's been an awful lot of fighting
and I spoke to people there who had no
time for zelenski particularly who
wanted it all to be over I had others
found others who
weren't sad about the Russians coming in
but then there were plenty of others
Russia it's you know it's a bit of a
false distinction to say though just
because ukrainians are native Russian
speakers they might automatically feel
that they are closer to Russia's
zelensky his first language is Russian
right and uh so it's like you know think
about the Irish you know they speak
English but there aren't all that many
Irish ones do you fear that we are
nearer a nuclear conflict than we've
ever been yes uh well since probably
since the Cuban Missile Crisis which was
when I was a small baby uh yeah I think
we do uh ever since the very start of
all this Putin has been using nuclear
rhetoric he hasn't done anything but
he's I think his rhetoric almost
normalizes the presence of that threat I
mean those of us you know those of us
who can remember 1989 and the fall of
the Berlin wall and the fall of the
Soviet Union in 1991 can remember
growing up I mean I grew up in the Cold
War I'm always in the background there
was this sense that if things did go
wrong internationally we might all end
up as radioactive dust right and sadly
my feelings come back and that's one of
the really dangerous things about this
crisis the fact that
Russia which actually has more nuclear
warheads than the US
is talking about using them of course it
could just be threats it could just be
talk but when someone who has an arsenal
of what six thousand plus Warheads
starts talking like that well you've got
to take it seriously the when you talk
about the Middle East with such
Authority I want to take you back to the
start of the Arab Spring and ask a
difficult question
would the world be better off if we
hadn't gone on a domino removing process
of all the dictators in the Middle East
would they have kept the lid on things
better than what's happened since well
the dictators pretty much are back
sometimes different faces and of course
Assad himself never left and actually
the the force to remove those people who
did go and that was the the ruler of
Tunisia and then the president of Egypt
and that it went on from there that came
very much from the streets it really did
because there's a large population of
mostly young people 60 under the age of
30 who were just fed up with these
countries run by autocrats corrupt uh
the the whole process of governance was
completely should we should we as we did
in Iraq should we be trying to instill
our Democratic Values into Middle
Eastern countries no democracy grows
from within a country we weren't given
it by people here in the UK or in
Western Europe we did it for ourselves I
think we can do things to help uh I
think for example uh we can help with
the building of Institutions that's a
really important part of it uh to have a
democracy you need courts that are
pretty honest reasonably honest so they
can enforce contracts it's not just
about voting it's about the legal system
it's about the respect for the rule of
law all of those things that's what
democracy is built on and it's wrong to
think that just because it's the Middle
East people don't want democracy I think
a lot of people would like to have have
it but now
quite a lot of people weren't confronted
Egypt's a good example when confronted
by this this tsunami of what seemed like
change actually were quite relieved yeah
when the military came back in strongman
CeCe who's there now who's the worst
dictator yeah Mubarak yes exactly uh
it's a fantastic book the making of the
modern Middle East of personal history
really cannot recommend it highly enough
um final question for the three of you
well I'll get into interview begin
militant who's been throwing paint all
over big Ben and Parliament on today are
any of you vegans vegetarians no they're
all meat eaters would would someone
chucking paint at Big Ben just when
we've repaired the damn thing make you
give up meat no absolutely not it's made
us talk about it now who's on your show
from having it no if they want to eat it
they're exactly that's my point you want
to eat your vegan Grill Eat Your vegan
Grill let me eat my meat and you
chucking playing a Big Ben isn't gonna
make me eat gruel it's not uh we'll have
that debate in a moment with one of the
protesters who thought it was a great
way to persuade me that'll be uh coming
out later and coming up next as a
Missouri school we're introduces the
practice of paddling seen here in a
school in Florida toughen up disciplined
should British schools follow suit are
our schools frankly going too soft
exploring a generation who just don't
respect the rules or is this actually
modern day torture well to make that
after the break thank you to my
brilliant pack Jeremy Jenny Esther
such a class wasn't it today yeah
great to see you we'll come back again
you can be uncensored here mate you can
say what you like
see you after the break
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
this is talk TV
[Applause]
welcome back to Facebook downstairs to
Crime Rising youth gang culture on the
up is the only way to get back control
of our streets and our schools to get
tougher on kids the school district in
the U.S state of Missouri has decided to
reinstate corporal punishment in its
classrooms allowing students to be
punished with a paddle like this under a
new policy well this video of a
five-year-old six-year-old girl I'm
sorry at an elementary school in Florida
shows what can happen the girl's mother
gave permission before this to happen
according to an official report but he's
bringing back this form of corporal
punishment of schools the best way to
root out the problem of rising crime and
disrespect well head teacher so safai
and former gang member and now
government advisor gwenton slowly join
me now welcome to both of you um you
grew up in in Jamaica yeah where there
was a lot of corporal punishment yeah
and then you came here where there
hasn't been for a long time sitting like
in schools in any authorized way what's
your view about this I think if we look
at historical records and see with the
rising gang crime to the point now where
we're at 3.4 million for each murder and
track back where a lot of this started
is from young people being excluded from
school and teachers feeling as if
they've got no control of their school
much less the classroom if that could
been prevented a lot of people would
have made it through to college and then
to University and had higher prospects
of actually gaining a job or something
people will feel looking at this paddle
you can't possibly use this on kids it
does look scary and as I said if you've
not come from somewhere where you've
actually gone through that system it
actually looks scary it looks like a
mini cricket bat looking at that but one
thing that we have to put in there is
that in America they've actually asked
the parents permission for this so it's
not just as if the schools implemented
it right the parents have to give the
permission
I mean that's the the point of this is
quite interesting parents want their
kids to be disciplined like this does
that change the the dial for you well
first and foremost there's no argument
hopefully anymore we've got to get
tougher with kids however this ship has
sailed our parents aren't allowed to hit
kids anymore here so the idea of using
an Implement you will not find a teacher
who will carry out that sort of
punishment when parents can be taken to
court for it and their own kids what
we've got to get tougher on is adults
that have long since abdicated their
responsibility of bringing up kids yeah
and I've got a whole list there let's
start with absent parents you know no
one wants to talk about it anymore but
you've just had everyone seen it
advert after advert from the media
finding a single parent mum with three
or four kids and no one wants to ask
okay would excuse bereavement well
where's the other parent here and of
course I've been teaching 42 years in
inner city areas and time and time again
people struggling with their kids but
they're struggling on their own why do
we accept the fact that people can have
children yet not take on board the
responsibility of bringing them up
properly what'd you say to that uh I
agree with you in some sense to that
because for what I do in the day-to-day
I look after people who witness
protection when I'm not running
elections but there are a lot of parents
struggling by themselves and when you
look at the murder rate a lot of these
young people are coming from broken
homes but to say that I came from a home
where I was a middle class young person
and I was still caught up because of the
environment I had a tutor and everything
else so it's not everyone sometimes the
excitement out there or the environment
that you have to go to school forces you
to either become a victim
yeah but but we know this but I wouldn't
even stop there parents single parents
is one thing let's talk about you've
talked about exclusion rates I know as a
head teacher and teachers well how to
account for everything you know exam
results exclusion rates you name it yeah
I've excluded kids in my time not
regretted a single one tried not to but
I'm telling you now happy to say it any
child that walks into my school with a
knife is not walking back in my school
again but have we gone too soft on this
in school yes and let me talk about the
fact there's
kids being excluded okay I can tell you
now there's very few that haven't had
Social Services involvement for donkey's
years we've been paying that money
that's been invested no good I want to
know and I've asked this question of my
local Authority for donkey's years you
know the youth offending team what are
the reoffending statistics on that I
know I'm accountable and I'm afraid the
message that adults now go back to
adults us abdicating our
responsibilities we're not bringing up
children properly we're not telling them
they have to take responsibility for
their actions see I I do know this is
this is right yeah I think the
disagreement is you think corporal
punishment can can solve this you were
in a gang I mean would it would it have
any impact if your kids excluded from
school if you bring them back and use
corporal punishment do they not deceive
that as basic extension of being in a
gang as I said it's about being tough
about giving support I've just run for
the mayor of Hackney which is unheard of
and if you look at this that's of that
how many people would have come from
where I've come from to be doing what
I'm doing so we need to show that there
is another way when you talk to young
kids young black kids in particular a
lot of the knife crime is a is endemic
amongst young black kids in London right
when you see them and you talk to them
how do you try and persuade them this is
not the way to go you you have to be an
example yourself and one thing you can't
be a broken man talking to a young
person that's making four thousand
pounds of a country like if a Young
Person's out there making more money
than you you then are struggling to tell
them to go and work in Tesco's or
somewhere else yeah but this is where I
mean I run two schools two thousand kids
camberwell and Peckham you know you
should see those kids brilliant kids
they know their place in terms of the
hair to teach teachers are in charge we
have rules and regulations and when they
break them there's no Fanning around in
terms of we make it damn clear you would
agree with that right damn clear that is
wrong you're going to get punished take
responsibility for it and we hope but I
know and I've already alluded to it we
have a whole bunch of professionals you
name it all around the place a youth
justice system there's broken Britain
for you telling these kids who everyone
knows I've got all sorts of examples
when I know the kids have admitted and
I've actually been sorry for doing
things wrong they've got their lawyers
saying no comment the parents are on
board with it but I'll get you off on a
technicality and then we're surprised
when they reach 18 we Chuck them in
prison we did a poll actually on social
media really asking about whether we
should bring back physical punishment in
schools to try and deal with this 56
percent said yes 44 said no it's it it's
an interesting result but what kind of
words well you have to look at that
piece is a lot of parents also
struggling so when their children come
home from terrorizing the teachers they
then terrorize their parents of course
so a lot of parents are there crying out
for help yeah well they get it in a good
school they get it in a good school they
come and ask for it because that there's
no one terrorizing teachers in my
schools and in a lot of good schools it
can be done without the paddle chaps
I've got to leave it there really good
debate thank you both very much I
appreciate it we're coming next animal
Rebellion paint Parliament white as
vegan activists played against a Big Ben
with tamed in a protest against milk is
this really the best way to make a point
to the new prime minister I'll go
toe-to-toe after the break with one of
these Millicent vegans he's demanding
well people like me should give up meat
and just eat gruel for the rest of our
natural lives
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
questions
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
well hungry vegans targeted Big Ben
today spraying white paint outside the
houses of Parliament they had Liz trust
his first prime minister's questions the
animal Rebellion protest group says the
white paint symbolizes milk and was
intended to represent the destruction of
a dairy industry also represents of
course petulant vandalism and the
destruction of historic building it's
the fourth day of action from the group
they've also cleared milk for Michelle's
supermarkets in four different cities
they say they're aiming to force Liz
trust to negotiating table but are they
in fact just annoying the hell out of
all of this or joining me now is a
spokesman for animal Rebellion orlo
Conklin who was at the protest at Big
Ben good evening to you thanks so much
for having me why would chucking paint
all over big bang persuade someone like
me to give up meat
yeah so as you and your viewers probably
know we're in a climate an ecological
emergency at the moment
um and so what we're doing is we're
asking the government to support farmers
and fishing communities in a transition
to a plant-based food system because we
know that animal agriculture is a
leading cause of the climate crisis and
so if we transition to a plant-based
food system we can free up vast amount
of land in the UK we can rewild and we
can draw carbon okay that's all fine
that wasn't my question my question is
why does chucking paint of a Big Bend
what is desecrating Trafalgar Square
with red dye chucking milk around
Harrods destroying Supermarket shells
and so how does that persuade me it
already likes eating meat why are you
going to persuade Me by being a vandal
don't get it yeah I think we're in an
incredibly difficult position at the
moment because we've been why are you
making it any easier because we've been
trying to talk about these things now
for a very long time and so we're at a
point where we need to escalate protest
so we can gain more media attention on
the subject
I don't know anyone I haven't heard
anyone go you know what I was a meat
eater and I saw Big Ben being desecrated
this great Monument of this country and
I thought I know what I'll do I'm gonna
go and give up meat and start eating
gruel I haven't heard a single human
being say that why would they I think
the purpose of protests is not
necessarily to win over people it's to
Bring the Noise to bring these important
conversations to the table Yeah but we
know the conversation you you're a vegan
right I'm a meat eater why can't we just
both live happily in each other's orbit
why can't you let me just get on with
intimate and you eat your gruel and
we're all go home happy because we know
animal farming and fishing are a leading
cause of the climate and we know having
a strictly vegan diet is bad for you as
well that's not true a lot of science
says it's bad for you that's not true it
is true what do you eat
I eat you eat almonds almond do you
drink almond milk eat almonds I think
you're digressing from them the big
issue I'm just curious what you eat
would you eat almonds I'm here to talk
about the climate crisis answer my
question do you eat almonds or drink
almond milk 30 million people in
Pakistan do you drink almond milk have
been affected here severe floods do you
drink almond milk I drink plant-based
milk you do you do and do you eat
avocados
I eat a plant-based diet asking the
government do you eat avocados
yes a leading study it's an interview
you don't just answer different
questions do you eat Avogadro I eat a
plant-based diet do you eat avocados
yes you do great do you know how
avocados and almonds get made absolutely
you do so you realize that in California
every year the six weeks they fly in
billions of bees to create your almonds
and avocados and in that process several
billion bees get murdered
this is a bee
right that's a b that's that last time I
checked is a living animal billions get
slaughtered so that you sitting here
pontificating in between smashing up our
buildings so that you can have your
almonds and your avocado and I say to
you why don't you care about the little
guys
can I say that it's totally hypocrisy
isn't it you don't care about bees being
murdered speak peers will you let me
speak why are you laughing it's not
funny I'd like to respond Minnie's
getting slaughtered and you're giggling
away like it doesn't matter whilst
destroying buildings because you care so
much about animals you don't care about
the little guys
do you I'm laughing because I'd like to
answer your question I've been brought
on the show to answer a question so I'd
really appreciate it I don't you're
never gonna persuade me because I think
you're a hypocrite like a lot of vegans
I've met you can all be as hangry as you
like and not have meat I don't believe
in the science of a strictly vegan diet
if if vegan diets work a lot of animals
would meet other animals do you believe
in the climate crisis yes well the
animal agriculture farming and fishing
is a leading cause of the climate crisis
you know what's also a leading cause of
climate crisis planes which carry vast
amounts of your avocados and your
almonds from California and fly them
thousands of miles to your table here in
your vegan cafes and then they also go
in trucks and that is an environmental
hazard too so you're not only are you
killing billions of bees you're
destroying the planet and yet you have
the brass neck to sit here in between
munching your almonds and your avogados
and start preaching to me about how
virtuous you are about not killing
animals
and saving the planet I'm like hang on
you're destroying the planet and you're
killing billions of bees I don't get it
can I respond and you're wrecking Big
Ben can I respond Trafalgar Square and
you're breaking up Harrods I hear that
you're very frustrated no not just find
these such
hypocritical nonsense how does he do
I would really like to respond to that
go on them
so a leading study from Oxford which is
the most comprehensive study on food and
the climate that has ever been done
before has said that animal products
that's farming
um animals and and fishing is the
leading College
I'm not finished sorry
is it be an animal
it's surpassing is it be an animal
Pierce can I is a bee an animal it
surpasses all oh
plant-based it's a b is one of these
things an animal
of course a bee is an animal if a bee is
an animal why are you slaughtering them
why are you not talking about the most
important issue that is facing because
it's rank hypocrisy it isn't hypocrisy I
meet so many vegans who who devour
avocados and almonds and don't seem to
realize it involves a Slaughter of
billions of bees both almonds and
avocados are less damaging to the plants
well they're less damaging and what
about how they get flown here from
California
that study in Oxford that is exactly
what it is no anyway look I'm starving
and uh you're not going to persuade me
and my response to you destroying all
these things is to have a Big Mac
because you know what it's a free
country it's a democracy and I'm allowed
to eat meat and I'm certainly allowed to
eat meat when someone who kills bees to
feed their avocado have it mine but
we're asking for the government to
support farmers
I'm Tony Dunn and this is talk TV the
most memorable moment in my career
without sounding completely conceited
has to be interviewing president Trump
in the open Office in the White House
particularly little red button he had on
his desk I have no idea what he did his
interview went on I wanted more rules
for the launch a nuclear strike on North
Korea or open up a sharp pit that I've
then fall into turn out he pressed it
right at the end of the interview and
then walked to Butler with a tray that
came back here it was a diet Cooper
[Music]
this is talk TV news
good evening I'm Nadira Tudor Liz truss
has vowed to focus on these serious
issues facing the UK including the cost
of living crisis she used her first pmqs
to rule out a new windfall tax on energy
Giants but she said she will announce
support for households tomorrow
meanwhile Robert Jen Rick is among the
high-profile names announced in the new
government today the former housing
secretary who supported Rishi sunak will
serve as health Minister while Steve
Baker will take up a role in the
Northern Ireland office and the Queen's
been forced to cancel a key meeting
after being told to rest by doctors Her
Majesty was due to officially swear new
cabinet ministers into their roles at a
privy council meeting but has postponed
after a full day yesterday
that's all for now we'll have more after
the talk
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]